on va faire une interview fromage ou
dessert
[Musique]
oui oui oui oui oui vous êtes mieux
comme ça ah merci bien je pensais
qu'elle aimait andreu sens est ce que
vous êtes plutôt chirac ou plutôt bush
chirac est ce que vous êtes plutôt jerry
lewis ou michel leeb attention
attention faut bien répondre sur le coup
parce que il ya un conte connaît très
très bien et nos impôts - est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt navarro ou colombo
quand vous êtes plutôt parisse texas où
pareille france ait accès vous êtes
plutôt star wars ou star ac
vous êtes plutôt indiana jones ou
patrick simpson john savoir et tu verras
d'une époque et ça fait que cette mise à
l'écart a peut-être qu'elle sait non non
non bon swing gum le tuto elvis presley
ou dick rivers est extra vous êtes
plutôt michael jackson ou marc dutroux
non quand même oui j'aurais peut-être
d'ici ou alors j'aurais fait sans mandat
et regarder ouais bon enfant
est ce que vous connaissez une émission
adamo puis des 3 donne un nom c'est la
première fois depuis 1965 babala et puis
avec copains m'ont tiennent aussi à
regarder l'an thierry ardisson cela
knitter il a du coeur thierry ardisson
cela knitter il a du coeur thierry
ardisson cela dit heures
il a du coeur ils arrêtent et dire la
vérité enfin même s'il a démenti l envie
d'enchaîner bien alors dernière question
tonia très très sérieusement est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt baseball ou baissent
tout court au lieu de ça j'étais au
baseball ou baise tout court alors j'ai
bien entendu
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus